let's get more on that now an indeed uh
gcse results should we shadow schools
minister stephen morgan is with us hi mr
morgan we wanted to go on to talk about
gcse results but let's talk about cost
of living to start with centrica british
gas doing their bit they're saying and
10 of their profits going to help those
most uh in need but that
in that is a drop in the bucket
you're absolutely right and that's why
labour set out a plan to tackle these
issues head-on in 24 hours we will know
the outcome of the latest energy price
cap and labour set out a plan as you
know 29 billion of investment benefit a
thousand pounds of every household i
think that would make a real difference
yesterday i was with a charity my own
constituency that was saying people are
really feeling the pinch and they're
hearing from people that they've not
heard from before
it's really unsettling for the british
public right now and the government are
nowhere to be seen on these issues yeah
but why do it across the board right why
not target it because it's affecting
everyone and you know we're doing
targeted support for those that need it
most in terms of
the changes to the pre-payment meter
system but also we want to make sure we
insulate more homes across the country
so a longer-term solution shorter-term
solution in terms of making sure
everyone gets a thousand pounds back so
that they can plan a bit better in some
of the face the challenges that they
face with rising fuel costs rising
energy costs and rising food costs and
this is not a short-term problem is so
we're chatting to um someone from the
resolution foundation earlier and he
says you know it's going to last two or
three years you're right and that's why
we need that longer term plan as well
and labor's looking at that but
insulating homes but strengthening the
windfall tax is absolutely the right
solution the conservative party
candidates the leadership of the country
and nowhere to be seen on these issues
and i think we're in a national
emergency now the government have got to
make a decision but we've got a zombie
government and that's why labour's got
credible plan that the government should
accept fracking where are we on fracking
well we do have concerns about fracking
what we do want to see is investment in
renewable energy sources we want to stop
the reliance on foreign gas and invest
in solar and other
other renewable energy commitments
that's why we've got a climate pledge
that will make a real difference in
terms of moving the country to more
renewable energy sources
what are your thoughts on suggestions
that schools may only be able to open
three days a week because they can't
afford their energy bills well i think
the best place for children to be is in
school and i'm deeply worried about the
impact that cost living crisis are
having on our schools we know from
research i've commissioned that energy
bills in schools at least doubling in
some cases trebling and again the gov
have no answers on this and the impact
of that will be on children's lives well
they disagree they say that they're
making money available well they're not
and we want to see much more action by a
government in terms of the increase in
funding they're giving to schools it
only gets it back to 2010 levels okay
look at the children's recovery plan the
person responsible for that in
government resigned because the
government couldn't deliver a program
that actually met the needs of our young
people and that's why labour's got a
positive plan that make a real
difference to every child and level the
playing field
um why are there regional disparities or
we're likely to see regional disparities
later on today with gcse results because
the government failed children a
children's recovery plan that hasn't
actually made a real difference across
the country if you look at normal why is
that the government's fault i mean
apparently it comes down to teachers and
the number of teachers and the quality
of teachers why is that the government's
fault well if you look at nosey say last
year four in ten young people achieved
past mark in english and maths in
buckinghamshire it's seven out of ten
there are real unequal outcomes across
the country the government distracted
with internal fights rather than
focusing on improving the lives of all
young people and labour's committed to
doing that with our children's recovery
plan well the government set up a
leveling up department in order to deal
with things like that well most
ministers don't seem to be able to
describe what leveling up means and what
we are seeing is a failure of government
investment across the country that's why
our plan would make a real difference
and look at the btec results last week
there are young people that still don't
have results from level three we've
heard that the level two results won't
be out today either you know we all
remember the chaos
of course it is because ultimately the
government was the commission
yeah government commissions exam boards
if i was the education secretary i'd be
pulling in those examples and saying how
do we sort this out as soon as possible
again the government of failing young
people
you're a former leader i'm not sure you
probably weren't in in office when um he
was in power talking about tony blair of
course he thinks that gcse's an a-levels
exam should be scrapped
well we want to see a system that's fit
for the future so we're looking at those
proposals as we are any other proposals
that come before us but i want to make
sure we've got curriculum that's broad
and varied for young people and a
curriculum that prepares people for work
and ready for life as well yeah we've
seen some kids just opening their
results i don't know if you were dashing
over weren't you so you didn't see but
they all got nines which is apparently
the equivalent to a stars good for them
very proud of them not every child will
find themselves in that position today
uh what's your advice to them well
that's what keeps me up at night and i
want to make sure every young person
whatever their background wherever
they're from succeed in life and
government interventions aren't making a
difference right now the national
tutoring program was meant to get kids
back on track failed taxpayers and it
failed young people and i want to make
sure whatever their background every
young person succeeds so we'll be
looking at the results really closely
today and labour's got an ambitious plan
to improve the lives of all young people
and youngsters who might be watching and
they don't get the exam results that
they're hoping for who's the first
person they should turn to
talk to their teachers talk to parents
it's a really unsettling time but know
that the country's behind them and want
them to succeed okay it's good to talk
to you thanks so much indeed for joining
us thank